[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 culture une émission pour
vous présenter les projets culturels de
l'été dans les yvelines
au programme aujourd'hui un ciné plein
air revient il encourt pour une
troisième édition film d'animation
classique comédie la commande et vous
propose de venir découvrir le septième
art
la deuxième édition de vive l'été à
guyancourt et lancer les acteurs
culturels de la ville se sont mobilisés
pour une programmation estivale à la
fiche de loisirs et spectacles
et puis la société trippin trotte vous
permet de parcourir le patrimoine
culturel de versailles le concept
découvrir les monuments et les oeuvres
de street art aux commandes d'une
trottinette électrique et je vous le
disais en titre le cinéma de plein air à
elancourt revient pour une troisième
édition des films d'animation des
classiques et des comédies il y en aura
pour tous les goûts
c'est organisé par la commanderie et ça
se passera tous les jeudis soirs
jusqu'au 26 août au grand parc de la
coulée verte
le reportage de nicolas landry et
juliette prigent
c'est un des rendez vous de l'été tous
les jeudis soirs jusqu'au 26 août un
film est projeté au grand parc de la
coulée verte à elancourt un cinéma en
plein air organisée par la commanderie
gratuit accessible à tous dans la limite
des 1000 places disponibles une manière
de partager un moment convivial en
famille ou entre amis c'est
effectivement l'occasion de redécouvrir
ou de découvrir des films on aurait
peut-être vu que sur petit écran
et là on a quand même la possibilité de
les voir sur un écran de 16 mètres de
large et aussi des films qu'on a
peut-être vu nous plus jeune et qu'on a
envie de faire découvrir aux enfants par
exemple
cette année encore la programmation est
variée de quoi plaire à petit et grand
vous pourrez par exemple rire devant la
comédie de wes anderson the grande
budapest hôtel le 15 juillet prochain à
22h
vous êtes superbe darling je vous assure
je ne sais pas quelle crème ils vous ont
appliqué à la morgue mais je veux la
paix c'est la bonne nouvelle de cette
troisième édition un film d'animation du
réalisateur japonais miyazaki est
projeté le 5 août à 21h il s'agit du
château ambulant jusque là cet animé
était interdit de diffusion cinéma de
plein air c'est donc une joie de pouvoir
le diffuser pour l'organisatrice
là c'est vraiment se laisser porter au
rêve après chacun y verra ce qu'il a
envie
la fin de cette histoire et surtout
aussi dans ce film c'est que on y
revient on y revient dans sa tête après
et on retrouve des plaies et surtout
c'est se laisser porter dans ce
magnifique univers oniriques de maaseik
[Musique]
sophie je ne veux plus fuir j'en ai plus
qu'assez de fuir
j'ai enfin trouvé quelqu'un à protéger
toi
pour terminer l'été un grand classique
du cinéma vous est proposé il s'agit des
goonies de steven spielberg et chris
columbus un film de 1985 à voir ou
revoir à l'eau cherry chez dans la salle
de lancia fard à joues et je vous
signale et nous apporte comme votre
dernière blague avec toutes ces petites
créatures qui se multipliaient quand on
leur jette et de l'ofce ça le théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines baisse le
rideau vendredi 23 juillet la saison
2021 2022 restera particulière avec la
crise sanitaire 2020-2021 pardon bilan
de la saison et programmation à venir
avec célia gars tsongo elle a rencontré
à lionel masse et à directeur de la
scène nationale regardez nous sommes sur
la scène du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en compagnie
de lunel masse et à bonjour bonjour vous
êtes le directeur du théâtre
alors avant de parler de la
programmation la saison à venir un 2021
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dresser le
bilan de cette saison en quelques mots
ça a été une saison comme vous
l'imaginez un peu étrange où beaucoup de
choses se sont déroulées en dehors du
théâtre puisqu'on à continuer à
intervenir en tournée itinérante dans
les établissements scolaires des
yvelines
on a continué toutes les actions que
l'on mène avec les artistes en dehors du
en dehors du théâtre et plus de théâtre
a lui même été assez actif puisqu'on a
eu à peu près quatre mois de répétitions
alors le théâtre ferme ses portes avant
le 23 juillet vous pouvez nous parler de
la programmation de cet été qui a
différent peut-être spectacles qui sont
joués alors un des avantages de cette
fermeture au public c'est que ça nous a
laissé un tout petit peu de temps pour
mettre en place certains chantiers dont
le chantier des escapades
l'année dernière on avait appelé ça
l'été culturel il ya eu trois concerts à
port-royal là on a essayé d'être plus
ambitieux et
artistiquement et géographiquement
puisqu'il va y avoir 10 ou 11 spectacles
de qui ont commencé d'ailleurs le 26 27
juin à port royal avec une adaptation
des trois mousquetaires qui vont se
poursuivre jusqu'au 10 7 au 18 septembre
prochain quand même une petite
interruption pendant pendant cet été
mais on va on va jouer à l'extérieur 10
11 12 spectacles à l'art vendredi 10
septembre c'est du coup le
l'inauguration a en tout cas de la
nouvelle saison 2021 2022
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer un
truc quel est le programme ou est-ce
qu'on rêvait de faire depuis un petit
moment et qu'on n'avait pas pu mettre en
place c'est faire une grande soirée
d'ouverture de la saison avec un
vernissage du vendredi 10 septembre à
partir de 18 heures il y aura le
vernissage d'une exposition qui
s'appelle anima ex musica qui
l'exposition qui va qu'on va conserver
pendant à peu près à peu près en moi qui
est assez exceptionnel puisque ce sont
des artistes des plasticiens qui recrée
des animaux en taille géante pas des
animaux des insectes des araignées des
arachnides à partir d'instruments de
musique qui ne sont plus utilisés
voilà donc il y aura cette exposition
qui sera dans tout le théâtre pendant un
mois à partir du 10 septembre
ensuite il y aura une brève présentation
de saison d'à peu près une heure et
ensuite les publics pourront aller sur
le quai françois truffaut pour voir un
spectacle encore spectacle de funambules
qui s'appelle résistent qui a été répété
d'ailleurs qu'il devait être joué sur
cette scène dans le courant de l'année
on a conservé le temps de répétition et
se sera jouée le 10 et 11 septembre
vendredi 10 et samedi 11 septembre à
20h30 qui est françois truffaut donc
voilà ça permet d'avoir une soirée assez
complète bien c'est noté on sera là
merci beaucoup d'exemple pour tous et
parfois reste la deuxième édition de
vivre l'été à guyancourt et l'on sait la
ferme de bel ébat la batterie les
maisons de quartier ou encore les
centres sociaux tous se sont mobilisés
pour célébrer l'été à guyancourt
au programme loisirs et spectacles le
reportage de bixente mais rien senti
steban avec lucas houdart vive l'été à
guyancourt la ville organise l'événement
pour la 2
année consécutive une manifestation
estivale proposant du sport du cinéma en
plein air des spectacles et des
animations dont les quartiers objectif
offrir un bol d'air frais aux habitants
en cette période compliquée le maire de
guyancourt a souhaité à à l'issue du
premier confinement voilà qu'on offre un
bol d'air un peu de un peu de joie aux
habitantes et aux habitants voilà au
sortir d'une période qui a été difficile
pour tout le monde et puis aussi où
beaucoup de personnes n'ont pas pu
partir en vacances une programmation co
construite avec les différents
équipements de la ville à la fiche des
spectacles gratuits en plein air et aux
styles variés
on présentera par exemple de 20 21 22 23
juillet monsieur blanchette et le loup
qui est une adaptation de la chèvre de
monsieur seguin en théâtre qui se jouera
dont quatre soirs différents dans quatre
quartiers différents de la ville
et puis on peut aussi citer le 24
juillet au jardin paul et virginie un
concert de djazia satour voilà qui sera
sans doute un très très beau moment
musical
mandel le temps fort de cette deuxième
édition aura lieu les 17 et 18 juillet
pour l'occasion le jardin de l'ermitage
ouvrira exceptionnellement ses portes au
public
il accueillera cinq à six spectacles par
jour on aura un carrousel forains on
aura du cirque on aura des musiques
actuelles on aura du compte de la
musique classique énormément de choses
et également des stands tenus par les
associations dans une logique de
développement durable
le dernier concert aura lieu le 28 août
l'ensemble national de reggae déambulera
dans le jardin paul et virginie au
quartier du pont du rotois informations
et programmation sur le site internet de
la ville à découvrir le patrimoine et
historiques et contemporains de
versailles en trottinette électrique
c'est le concept proposé par la société
trippin trotte elle propose un parcours
culturel autour des monuments de la
ville et du street art
l'interview à des fondateurs recueillis
par nicolas landry
[Musique]
il ya un passif est formel certaines
clés ne peut pas leur couleur d'autres
un peu moins
les artistes ont voulu voilà représenter
la nature et je pense aussi voilà notre
relation avec la nature
il mourra s'associe avec tout mon corps
est où on veut aussi mettre mon relation
avec la venue d'afrique mobile pour
ancien de par ce mouvement dans l'aï
beaucoup d'artistes comme wenger comme
cyclope
tous sont venus à versailles faire de
l'art de rue union qui conduit c'est de
pouvoir faire découvrir et au prônant la
lutte de la salle
chaque fois qu'on a un contrat de
commercialisation ou un accord avec un
site
on a à coeur de se renseigner
historiquement sur ce qui est présent et
de la prendre avant effectivement tous
les centres d'intérêt qu'on peut être
[Musique]
et pour clore ce dernier 7,8 culture de
la saison je vous propose de découvrir
nos coups de coeur des événements
culturels à venir expositions spectacles
ou encore déambulation il y en a pour
tous les goûts le top 5 des rendez vous
culturels de l'été et de la rentrée
c'est maintenant en remettant toujours
hollande
nous pourrions faire le jour même
[Musique]
le mentalisme c'est se connecter à
l'autre c'est écouter ce que l'autre dit
même lorsqu'il ne parle pas
[Musique]
tu sais moi quand j'étais contre arrêté
ou que j'ai pas à conserver question je
me fais un petit match
là c'est important attends moi j'ai
cherché à 10 h 2
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 culture merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi rendez vous à
la rentrée pour des émissions inédites
d'ici là je vous souhaite de très bonnes
vacances bel été sur tv 78
[Musique]